welcome to another edition of famous
Friday where we modeled the success of
famous entrepreneurs whatever problem
you have right now somebody has already
solved it and instead of trying to
figure out the solution yourself to
everything go and model success
today's lesson is think big but start
small and it comes from the founders of
Harley Davidson the Harley Davidson was
started by two friends William Harley
and Arthur Davidson and they loved going
fishing and they always had the bicycle
to get to their fishing spot they wanted
to take the work out of bicycling get to
their fishing spots faster and said what
if we attach a motor to this bicycle so
we can get to our fishing hole faster
and they made their first prototype and
I said you know what this thing actually
works we can get to our fishing spot
faster we can have more free time we can
have a lot more fun and so ii decided to
start a company but they didn't do the
classic mistake that so many
entrepreneurs make they didn't go out
and start investing into equipment and
investing into a factory and investing
into inventory they didn't go and spend
a lot of money because they didn't have
a lot of money what they did was they
set up in their backyard that had this
little shed and they posted Harley
Davidson on the door and they got to
work in their backyard they got to work
with what they had they may have had big
visions but they started small and in
1903 they made three motorcycles in 1904
they made three more motorcycles in 1905
they made seven motorcycles and then
they figured it out they figured out how
to make motorcycles properly they
figured out how to sell the motorcycles
that they are making there was demand
there was interest they refined the
process they were now ready for
expansion and then they went out in
their fourth year to get a new plant to
actually go and build these things they
set their own shop a real shop not just
a backyard shop and they made 50
motorcycles that year and then they
eventually hit a thousand motorcycles
and 3,000 motorcycles and 5000
motorcycles and you can see their
success store in their growth but the
seat
it was right there at the beginning they
may have had this big vision for a
company but they started with what they
had and too many entrepreneurs are so
focused on what they don't have right
you focus on the money you don't have
you focus on that investor you don't
have you focus on the customer that you
don't have instead of focusing on what
you don't have you got to do what you
came with what you do have you start
small you have that big goal that big
vision that's awesome that you need that
that keeps you motivated that keeps you
excited that's the that's the end
picture of what you're trying to
accomplish but you got to act nobody's
coming to save you this is on you to get
started in any small way you can to move
your business forward even if that means
a backyard shed you're working with what
you have to start building your dream
think big but start small believe those
are watching the video if you like this
you want to see more please subscribe to
the channel it means a lot to me
and I'll see you soon